I hate to say it. I don't want to say
it, but I told you so. 2026 is the year
of disclosure. They've been telling us
with the predictive programming. There
was a whole documentary that was
interviewing military personnel and all
of them were saying, "Look, if if it
wasn't for all of us coming together, I
couldn't say this stuff because I might
be killed for it, but we're we're
banding together. We're going to tell
the truth." And then Stephen Spielberg
came out with Disclosure Day and
everything is pointing to we're about to
be told aliens are real and I think
we're going to be told that they're here
living among us and have been for
thousands of years and that they're not
harming us. So, it's okay. They're
friendly. And then there's going to be
the big reveal. Things are about to get
crazy, guys. I'm just blown away. I'm
blown away that it's already happened
because this was December 16 when I was
on Mark Sergeant's show and said this.
We're they're about to have disclosure I
believe probably next year.
>> Full disclosure
prediction.
>> Yeah, I think I I and Mark was like bold
bold prediction. Yeah, it was. And then
here uh three weeks ago, I'm not a
prophet. I'm not a date setter, but I
believe that 2026 is the year of full
disclosure. And I said it a couple
times, but this is what's going on right
now. Trump released this on all his
social media and it says, "Based on the
tremendous interest shown, I will be
directing the Secretary of War and other
re relevant departments and agencies to
begin the process of identifying and
releasing government files related to
alien and extraterrestrial life,
unidentified aerial phenomenon or UAP,
and unidentified flying objects, UFOs,
and any and all other information
connected to these highly complex but
extremely interesting and important
matters. Trump was actually questioned
by somebody and said, "Hey, Obama said
that uh that there are aliens or
something." And Trump was like, "Oh,
he's not supposed to be saying that
stuff. That's classified or whatever."
This what he posted is not going to be
like, "Oh, I'm going to let you know
everything about the UFO files. There
really aren't any UFOs." That's not
what's going to come. We're going to be
told something is going on. We've
already been being told. We've we've had
soft disclosure for I don't know close
to four, five years now. I know I made a
documentary for for Little Light Studios
called Disclosed Deceiving the World. If
you check that out, that was over four
years ago. And they were already telling
us, "Yes, we see things every day. We
don't know what they are. They're flying
around. We don't know what they are.
They're not our technology. It's not
their technology." Then they started
talking about drones, these carsiz
drones in New Jersey, but it wasn't just
Jersey. It was Hawaii. It was all over
the world. And they were saying, "Yeah,
we don't know what it is, but it's okay.
Just keep shopping. Life is usual." They
seem to be okay. They seem to be
benevolent.
They said they even said, "We don't know
what this is." And people were like,
"That's crazy." But it now we don't even
think about it. Right? Then they were
telling us, "Yeah, we communicate with
non-human intelligences. They're having
US congressional hearings. See, step by
step, they tell us a little bit at a
time to the point where we we let our
guard down. We're like, "Oh, yeah, big
deal. Drones. I don't see them anymore."
So, we just go on with life, right? And
so, this is what they're doing. Soft
disclosure, warming us up to the idea of
getting used to things flying around in
our skies, interactions, communication,
uh, sightings, all that stuff. Until
now, the big reveal. And what some
people say is that this is a distraction
from the Epstein files. I have a
different spin on that and I'm going to
do a show on that tomorrow deeper.
But what I believe is not that this is
to distract from the Epstein files. I
think that Satan has planned all this
out for years in advance to bring about
to collapse the whole structure, the
whole trust in everything to where we
can't trust man at all because they're
all sexual deviants. They're all
cannibals
to the point where we can't trust man
and it's going to be order out of chaos.
When we can't trust anyone, Satan is
going to appear as an angel of light
doing lying signs and wonders, and we're
going to think Christ has returned
because the world is so bad.
Everything's coming out to light, and
we're going to believe this is Christ.
Nobody could do this except Jesus.
Because we're not reading the Bible.
We're not reading that Satan is actually
going to become an angel of light and do
lying, signs, and wonders and miracles.
It says miracle working demons are going
to deceive the entire world. We're going
to look at all those scriptures. We're
going to talk about that right now. You
see this is all the news right now. Two
and three days ago, government UFO
files. It's all talking about Trump is
about to release these things.
And so I'm starting to see posts like
this. The rapture has come. What
rapture? We took them all away. Don't
believe the lie. Jesus is coming. And so
people are starting to say Christians
are saying that this whole UFO thing is
going to explain away the rapture. I I
keep seeing these posts in case we
disappear suddenly. It wasn't aliens.
Jesus called his own. And here's this is
actually a tract and it says UFOs or
rapture. If millions of people have
suddenly vanished, don't believe the lie
of UFOs.
Now, is this true? Can this possibly be
true that UFOs are going to explain away
the rapture? We're going to look at the
scriptures and the Bible alone. Here on
this channel, we don't care about
feelings, tradition, what my pastor
said, what does the word of God say?
That's why it's the candid truth because
the word of God is the only source of
truth. Jesus said, "I am the way, the
truth, and the life, and he is the
word." Right? So, we cannot get our
beliefs from anyone. I don't care what
denomination. I don't care what uh
degree you have or what kind of vision
you had or dreams. I've heard all of it.
Okay? I've heard so many people say, "I
had a dream about this and it's got to
be real and all this stuff. What does
the word of God say?" We're living in an
age of deception.
There is a deceiver out there and he can
do lots of things. He can give people
dreams. If you don't believe that, just
listen to some testimonies of newagers
who come out of their body. You know,
they have astral projection and meet
with ascended masters and all this
stuff. Satan has the power to give you
visions if there's any open door in your
life. And you might not think, you might
think, I'm a Christian. There's no open
doors in my life. But what's in your
movie drawer? What's in your CD drawer?
What's in your book cabinet? What kind
of decorations are decorating your
walls?
There are many things that open up
doors.
What does the word of God and the word
of God alone say? So, first of all,
there are a ton of movies about this
subject. There's all these movies like
Left Behind, even with Nicholas Cage. I
mean, Hollywood jumped on the bandwagon
of promoting the pre-tribulation
rapture. Are we going to get our
theology from Hollywood? I would say
that's not a good source. Rapture
Palooa, a comedy that was mocking the
rapture, left behind with Kurt Cameron,
who now he does not believe in the
pre-trib rapture. He was the poster boy
for the pre-trip rapture. He was the
face of the Left Behind series and he no
longer believes in the pre-tribulation
rapture. So, this idea has been put out
for years. I'm talking like in the 60s
and the 70s, they had movies like A
Thief in the Night. It it comes from the
verse in 2 Peter 3:10 that says, "But
the day of the Lord shall come as a
thief in the night, in the which the
heavens shall pass away with a great
noise, and the elements shall melt with
fervent heat, and the earth also, and
the works that are therein shall be
burned up." Notice what the whole
scripture says. You know, you make a a a
title of a movie called a thief in the
night, and the whole storyline is about
Jesus comes like a thief. Nobody sees
him. People vanish and then for seven
years there's people alive on earth
through the tribulation.
But what about when you read the whole
scripture? It doesn't just say, "But the
day of the Lord shall come as a thief in
the night." Case closed. Read the whole
verse. What's happening in this same
scenario?
But the day of the Lord shall come as a
thief in the night in the which meaning
in that very same moment the heavens
shall pass away with a great noise and
the elements shall melt with fervent
heat.
The earth also and the works that are
therein shall be burned up. Notice it
doesn't say anything about he's going to
come as a thief in the night and the
those who are left behind are going to
spend seven years of tribulation. It
literally says when he comes as a thief,
the earth is going to be burned up. That
means there is no tribulation time
period where there's only non-believers
and the righteous have been raptured up.
But that's just one verse. Let's study
line upon line because we can't make
theology out of one verse. The only
other time we see this thief in the
night terminology is in 1 Thessalonians
5 2-3. And it says, "For yourselves know
perfectly that the day of the Lord so
cometh as a thief in the night." And
then what's the rest of the verse say?
For when they say shall say peace and
safety, then sudden destruction
cometh upon them as travail upon a woman
with child, and they shall not escape.
Are you noticing that when he comes as a
thief in the night, in that same day
there is sudden destruction, not well
seven years later then the earth will be
destroyed. No, we just saw line upon
line that the earth and the elements
will be burned up. Sudden destruction.
There was another movie called End of
the Harvest. It came out in 1998.
And it comes from this parable in
Matthew 13 24-30. And it says, "The
kingdom of heaven is likened unto a man
which swed good seed in his field. But
while men slept, his enemy came and
sowed tears among the wheat and went his
way. But when the blade was sprung up,
and brought forth fruit, then appeared
the tears also. The servants of the
householder came and said unto him,
"Sir, did not thou we sow good seed in
thy field? From whence then hath it
tears?" He said unto them, "An enemy
hath done this?" The servants said unto
unto him, "Wilt thou then that we go and
gather them up?" But he said, "Nay,
listen to this. They're saying, "Should
we not gather up the wicked?" And he's
saying, "No, lest while ye gather up the
tears or the wicked, ye root up also the
wheat with them." So listen to this next
line.
Let both grow together
until the harvest.
And in the time of the harvest, I will
say to the reapers, gather ye together
first the tears, and bind them in
bundles to burn them, but gather the
wheat into my barn. Are you seeing this?
This is mindblowing. For anyone that's
teaching the pre-tribulation rapture,
this actually says, "Let them grow
together until the harvest and then does
it say he's going to gather the
righteous first?" No, it says he's going
to gather the wicked first to burn them
and leave the righteous. He clarifies
because this is a parable and the
disciples are asking like, "Okay, what
did this parable mean?" And he says, "He
that seweth the good seeds is the son of
man." So Jesus is the one who makes us
righteous. The field is the world. The
good seed are the children of the
kingdom, but the tears are the children
of the wicked one. The enemy that swed
them is the devil. The harvest is the
end of the world. It doesn't say the
harvest is seven years before the end of
the world. It says, "The harvest is the
end of the world, and the reapers are
the angels, and therefore the tears are
gathered and burned in the fire. So
shall it be in the end of this world.
The Son of Man shall send forth his
angels, and they shall gather out of his
kingdom all things that offend, and them
which do iniquity, and shall cast them
into a furnace of fire. There shall be
wailing and nashing of teeth. Then shall
the righteous shine forth as the son in
the kingdom of their father. Who hath
ears to hear? Let him hear. That is my
prayer right now. I pray that someone
here has ears to hear and they're not
falling for this pre-tribulation rapture
scenario anymore. That they're not
waiting around like, you know what,
before it gets really bad, I'm going to
be sucked out of here. I've had people
literally tell me, "I don't even need to
study prophecy. I wanted to study
prophecy and the mark of the beast and
things like that." And they're like,
"Nope. I don't even need to know about
it because I'm not going to be here. I'm
getting sucked out." Imagine the
disappointment when they are here for
the mark of the beast and the
tribulation and all of it, right? It
says, "Then shall the righteous shine
forth as the sun in the kingdom of their
fathers." So, it's saying that the
wicked will be taken away, right?
They're going to be taken and burned and
the righteous are going to be left.
Isn't that interesting? Satan flips
everything on its head. Satan has
actually convinced us that we want to be
taken and not left behind, right?
But this verse says that the wicked will
first be taken to be burned and the
righteous will be left shining like the
sun. Shining in the sun. All right, I'm
going to prove that even more in another
verse if that just like blew you away. I
know it did for me. So, I'm going to do
a comparison here side by side. This is,
you know, his parable next to his
explanation. And it says, "Let both grow
together until the harvest." And then
you see the harvest is the end of the
world. So the wicked and the righteous
are going to grow together until the end
of the world, not seven years before the
end of the world. Then in blue it says,
"Gather ye together first the tears to
bind them in bundles of burn." And in
blue you see over here it says, "So
shall it be in the end of the world. The
Son of Man shall send forth his angels,
and they shall gather out of out of his
kingdom all things that offend, and them
that do iniquity, and shall cast them
into a furnace of fire. There shall be
wailing and nashing of teeth. I mean, if
you guys are having trouble with this,
please screenshot this. Compare this
side by side. Gather the wheat into my
barn. And he said, 'Then shall the
righteous shine forth as the sun in the
kingdom of their father.' It sounds like
we want to be left behind according to
that verse. We don't want to be taken
and burned. We want to be left behind.
But that's that sounds like a really far
reach right now because we've been so
programmed to believe that you don't
want to be left behind, right? That's
what this movie is all about. And you
know, here's the synopsis that the
entire planet is basically through the
tribulation and people are disappearing.
And so, let's look where they get this
from. They get it from Matthew 24 37-4.
And it says, "But as the days of Noah
were, so shall also the coming of the
Son of Man be. For as in the days that
were before the flood, they were eating
and drinking, marrying and giving and
marriage, until the day that Noah
entered into the ark, and knew not until
the flood came and took them all away.
So shall also the coming of the son of
man be. Then shall two be in the field.
Then one shall be taken and the other
left. All right, this is amazing, man.
When when God revealed this to me, I was
so shocked and and full of joy because
the truth will make you free, right?
We've been taught you don't want to be
left behind. I want you to notice the
terminology here. Took them all away. Is
that the righteous or the wicked? When
it says took them all away, that's
talking about the wicked. It's saying
that the flood came and took them all
away. So, we know for a fact that right
now we're talking about the flood came
and took the wicked away. And then it
goes on and says that two will be in a
field and one shall be taken.
What What word are we seeing here? Took
and taken. It says that his second
coming will be as in the days of Noah
when the wicked were taken into
destruction. And then he goes on and
says, "Two will be in the field and one
shall be taken by destruction
and one will be left alive." Right?
Isn't that mind-blowing? We've literally
been deceived. Like everything that
we've believed about this topic has been
flipped on its head and we've been
believing that we don't want to be left
behind. We want to be taken when in
reality taken means destruction. It says
right here, I tell you, in that night
there shall be two men in one bed, and
one shall be taken and the other shall
be left. Two women shall be grinding
together. The one shall be taken and the
other left. Two men shall be taken in
the field, the one will be taken, and
the other left. And they answered and
said unto him, "Where, Lord?" They're
saying, "Where are these people going to
be taken?" That's what they're asking.
Where? And he said unto them,
"Wheresoever the body is, thither will
the eagles be gathered together." Now,
he is not talking about um those that
were taken, they were taken up into the
sky with the eagles. He's saying your
body, your carcass is left for
destruction, and the eagles are going to
be gathered together to eat your corpse.
And you'll see that right here in
another parallel. Well, it says,
"Behold, I have told you before,
wherefore, if they shall say unto you,
Behold, he is in the desert. Go not
forth. Behold, he's in the secret
chamber. Believe it not. For as the
lightning cometh out of the east, and
shineth even into the west, so shall
also the coming of the Son of Man be."
Now, check it out. For who? For
wheresoever the carcass is,
there will the eagles be gathered
together.
Right? So it's not saying you want to be
taken up with the eagles. No, it's
saying if you are taken, you are
destroyed and your body, your carcass is
left for the eagles. And then notice
this. Immediately after the tribulation,
this doesn't say before the tribulation.
Immediately after the tribulation of
those days, the sun shall be darkened
and the moon shall not give her light.
I mean, this is so clear, guys.
And you you got to continue because you
you might say, "Well, it's just out of
order a little bit." No, we've already
saw that there's there's one taken, one
left, one's going to be eagle food. And
it says, "The moon shall not give her
light, and the stars shall fall from
heaven, and the powers of the heavens
shall be shaken, and then shall appear
the sign of the Son of man in heaven.
And then shall all the tribes of the
earth mourn, and they shall see the Son
of Man in the clouds of heaven with
power and great glory. And he shall send
his angels with a great sound of a
trumpet, and they shall gather together
his elect from the four winds of the
earth, from the from one end of heaven
to the other.
I hope this is clear, guys. We're
hearing right now, this whole subject is
about a trumpet sound,
the angels coming and gathering the
elect. That is the rapture, guys. The
second coming is the rapture. There's no
third coming. Well, not until after the
millennium. There is only a second
coming. And that is the rapture. And
when does it happen? Immediately after
the tribulation.
It's happening after these carcasses are
being eaten by the eagles.
Man, I hope this is clear to you guys.
in the blink of an eye. This is another
movie put out by Pure Flicks. And where
do they get this title from? Remember,
all these movies are teaching you that
you're going to be snatched up before
times get really hard, before seven
years of tribulation. That's what all
these movies are teaching. Yet, the very
title of the movie comes from a
scripture that says something completely
contrary to what they're teaching. This
is this is how deceived we are in this
world today. in the blink of an eye.
This comes from 1 Corinthians 15:51-53.
And it says, "Behold, I show you a
mystery. We shall not all sleep, but we
shall all be changed in a moment. In the
twinkling of an eye, at the last
trumpet." When does it happen? When are
we changed? In a twinkling of an eye. At
the last trumpet. For the trumpet shall
sound, and the dead shall be raised
incorruptible,
and we shall be changed. For this
corruptible must put on incorruption,
and this mortal must put on immortality.
I want you to notice something.
We just read that when this event
happens, there's a trumpet sound.
There's angels coming to gather up those
who were dead in Christ, they rise
first. Those who are alive and remain
will be caught up. There's a trumpet
sound. All this is one event. There's
not two resurrections of the righteous.
Okay, do we agree on that? How how many
resurrections of the righteous are
there? One.
Because some people will say, "No, no,
you're looking at the second coming and
mixing it up with a pre-tribulation
rapture. I'm about to destroy all that.
That's all going to be debunked by the
word of God because this is all one
event.
The dead in Christ only rise one time."
And right here it says that the dead
shall be raised when? At the last
trumpet.
That's when it happens. We have 1
Corinthians 15:52 and 1 Thessalonians
4:16-1 17. And they're both the same
event. Check it out. In a moment, in the
twinkle of an eye, at the last trump,
for the trumpet shall sound, and the
dead shall be raised incorruptible, and
we shall be changed. That's 1
Corinthians 15:52. Now, check this one
out. For the Lord himself shall descend
from heaven with a shout, with the voice
of the archangel, and with the trump of
God. We hear a trumpet, a trumpet, and
the dead in Christ shall rise first.
Look, we have the the dead being raised,
the dead being raised, the resurrection
of the righteous. There's only one
event. Then we which are alive and
remain shall be caught up to meet with
them in the clouds to meet the Lord in
the air. And so shall we ever be with
the Lord. I hope this is clear, guys.
We're looking studying line upon line,
precept upon precept, here a little,
there a little by the mouth of two or
three witnesses. That's the only way you
can come to the truth. You can't get,
you can't take one little verse, part of
a verse that says the Lord comes as a
thief in the night. You can't take one
little verse and say we'll be changing
mo in a twinkle of an eye. Look at the
context. What's going on? The last
trumpet. We're going to get we're going
to look into that. Why is that
important?
Because in Revelation 8, we see
something. And when he had opened the
seventh seal, there was silence in
heaven about the space of a half an
hour. And I saw seven angels which stood
before God, and to them were given seven
trumpets. All right, there's seven
trumpets in the book of Revelation. What
are these trumpets doing? And the seven
angels which had the seven trumpets
prepared themselves to sound. The first
angel sounded and there followed hail
and fire mingled with blood and there
and they were cast upon the earth and
the third part of the trees were burned
up and all the green grass was burned
up. This is a plague.
Each trumpet, if you were to read all of
Revelation, you'll see that every time a
trumpet sounds, a plague is poured upon
the earth. So the last trumpet would be
when? After the plagues. It can't be the
last trumpet unless it's after these
seven trumpets. Right? So the the last
trumpet which is the sound of us raising
out of the graves and putting on
incorruption and immortality and being
caught up to meet the Lord in the air
happens after seven trumpets that are
pouring plagues upon the earth.
And I've heard so many people try to
logic this and reason it and rationalize
it instead of going to the scriptures
and they're like, "God's not a
wifebeater. He's not going to leave his
church, his bride in the earth as he's
pouring down plagues upon the earth."
Well, did he do it in in Egypt? Israel
was still in Egypt when 10 plagues came
down. 10. We're talking about seven in
the book of Revelation. But God's people
were still in Egypt when 10 plagues came
down and none of them were affected by
it. Their firstborn didn't die. They
weren't affected by the bloody waters or
the or the frogs or any of this stuff.
God protected them through the
tribulation. God protected Shadrach,
Meshach, and Abedneo through the fiery
furnace. He protected Noah and his
family through the flood. These people
were never taken off the earth. They
were always here remaining and it's no
different. These are all parallels to
what we'll be going through. And the
reason I'm so passionate about this and
I and I I just love the truth. I want
people to not be deceived. I don't want
people sitting around twiddling their
thumbs waiting for the rapture thinking
that this alien thing is going to
explain away the rapture. It's not.
There's going to be UFOs and we're going
to be here for it. It's there's going to
be a false Christ coming, an antichrist,
Satan literally manifesting, pretending
to be Christ, doing lying signs and
wonders, and if it were possible, would
deceive the very elect. We're going to
be here for it, for the mark of the
beast, for the Antichrist. Be ready. Be
prepared for what is soon to come upon
this earth. This is why I'm passionate
about it. I do not want anyone to be
taken off guard. I don't want anyone to
be destroyed because they're not ready.
I remember when God showed me this
verse. I'd use this verse many times to
to talk about what happens when you die
and how you remain in the grave until
until the second coming of Christ. But
then God showed me something in here
that proved
when the rapture happens.
This is in Job 14:10-15.
And it says, "But man dieth and wasteth
away. Yay, man giveth up his up the
breath. And where is he? As the waters
fail from the sea, and the flood decayth
and dryth up, so man lith down and
riseth not till the heavens be no more."
So, this is kind of a different topic.
But if you want to know what happens
when you die, Job tells you, you lie
down and you rise not until the heavens
be no more. When are the heavens going
to be no more? We just read that, right?
As a thief in the night, till the
heavens shall pass away with a great
noise. That's the second coming of
Christ. You will remain in your grave if
you're not alive when Christ returns.
Those who have died are not rising till
the heavens be no more, till the second
coming of Christ. They shall not awake
nor be raised
out of their sleep. Oh that thou
wouldest hide me in my grave. This is
where the dead are. They're in their
grave. They're not in heaven conscious.
They're not in hell. They're not in
shield uh or in Abraham's bosom. They
are in the grave. Daniel says that
they're going to rise out of the dust of
the earth. Many shall rise out of the
dust of the earth. Some to everlasting
contempt and some to everlasting life.
But stick with me. That thou wouldest
keep me secret when until thy wrath be
passed. Pay attention to that
because when is the resurrection of the
righteous,
right? The resurrection of the righteous
is at the second coming. And when does
it happen? After God's wrath is passed.
So I've heard some people say, "Look, I
I'm not preerttrib. I'm I'm post
tribrath."
I've heard that version, too. There's
preerttrib, mid-trip, post-trib,
pre-wrath, and then there's just
post-trib. And so people like Kent
Hovind, he used to be preerttrib, but
now he's preerttrib or yeah, he's uh
posttrib pre-wrath. But this right here
says that the dead will remain in their
grave until God's wrath is passed. which
means after the plagues, meaning the
resurrection of the dead in Christ and
the rapture is happening after the
plagues
that thou would disappoint me a set time
and remember me. If a man dies, shall he
live again? All the days of my appointed
time will I wait until my change come.
What did Paul say? In a moment, in the
twinkling of an eye, we shall be
changed.
The Bible is amazing. Job is the oldest
book in the Bible. It's it's older than
Genesis when it was written. Moses wrote
Genesis after Job wrote this.
And and it says he is verifying what
Paul says in the New Testament, talking
about the change and when we're going to
rise up out of the grave. And when does
it happen? after God's wrath is passed.
Line upon line, precept upon precept.
Revelation 16:1 says, "And I heard a
great voice out of the temple saying to
the seven angels, go your ways and pour
out the vials of the wrath of God upon
the earth." If anyone's confused about
what God's wrath is, this wrath that's
going to have to be passed before our
change comes, we're told right here in
Revelation, the wrath of God are these
vials of plagues. It's happening after
the plagues. 1 Corinthians 5:51-52
says, "Behold, I show you a mystery. We
shall not all sleep, but we shall all be
changed in the moment in the twinkle of
an eye at the last trumpet. For the
trumpet shall sound, and the dead shall
be raised incorruptible, and we shall
all be changed. When does that happen?
After God's wrath is passed. It's so
clear, guys. There's no way if you read
the Bible and study this topic out,
there is absolutely no way you can be
confused on the timing of the rapture.
you will not see anything in the word of
God. I challenge you if you see it.
Please put a comment in the in the
comment section. I want to know. I mean,
if the pre-tribulation rapture is real,
I want to know because that's exciting
news. But I've studied this out for
years, and all I find is more evidence,
more evidence that we are here through
the plagues. And and if you're on God's
side, if you are sealed, you will not be
harmed through those plagues.
It actually says that we will be kept
from that hour of temptation, right? We
will be protected through that hour of
temptation. That's what the word of God
promises. And that's a a great promise
to cling to.
Matthew 24:19 through30 tells us
immediately after the tribulation. I
know we already looked at this. I just
want to reiterate it. Immediately after
the tribulation is when you see all
these signs of the coming of the son of
man.
And Revelation 22:11 says, "He that is
unjust, let him be unjust still. He
which is filthy, let him be filthy
still. And he that is righteous, let him
be righteous still. And he that is holy,
let him be holy still." Why do I show
this verse? Because remember Jesus told
a parable. Let them both grow together.
The the wheat and the tears. Let them
grow together until the end of the
earth. Now this verse right here would
make absolutely no sense
if there was a pre-tribulation rapture.
Because what he's saying right here is
saying them who are unjust, I'm drawing
a line in the sand. This is your hour of
pro your your probation has closed. If
you're unjust, that's it. You do not get
to make a change. If you're holy,
let them be holy still. I've heard
people say that there is a there are
tribulation saints, people that miss the
rapture and they're living seven years
of hell on earth. And during that time,
they get a choice to repent and give
their heart to Christ. And then at the
end of the seven years tribulation or if
they get their heads cut off, they'll
actually be saved. They get a second
chance. That's what I've been told. But
in the same breath, people will say when
the rapture happens, the Holy Spirit is
removed from the earth. Tell me, how can
you be how can you become a Christian if
the Holy Spirit is removed from the
earth? The Holy Spirit is the one who
leads us and draws us to Christ. If the
Holy Spirit's removed, there's no chance
of salvation.
And right here when it's saying let him
as just and unjust and all this stuff,
this this scenario makes no sense. If
the righteous are removed, if there are
no righteous,
then this makes no sense. I I don't know
if that makes sense to you guys.
Revelation 22:12 says, "And behold, I
come quickly and my reward is with me to
give every man according to his uh to
his works shall be." That's the next
verse.
So the context of this unjust stays
unjust and righteous stays righteous is
not seven years before tribulation
because the very next verse says I come
quickly with my reward.
This this unjust and just line in the
sand is at his second coming when he's
coming with his reward. I'm wanting to
show you something with these verses
because I'm I'm bringing this back to
this whole UFO alien thing. Okay. Let no
man deceive you about the timing of the
coming of Christ. He said, "If they say
I'm in the desert, don't go. If they say
I'm in the secret chambers, look not."
He says, "Don't even don't even
contemplate entertaining that because
you will fall for the deception. The
deception is going to be so great that
if you look upon it, you will fall for
it." The only way we will not be
deceived by Satan appearing as a
supernatural being doing miracles
is to study prophecy to understand the
timing of prophecy to understand how
these events are going to play out or we
will be deceived. And I believe that
Satan will even set up a false
antichrist to overthrow and then appear
so that even those who are looking for
an antichrist will say, "Well, Trump was
the antichrist and he got overthrown by
this uh supernatural being. It has to be
Jesus." But remember, it's not Christ
unless we're raising out of the graves
and being caught up to meet the Lord in
the air. He's not setting foot on earth.
We're meeting him in the air. All of
this is so important to understand. And
it says in Revelation 13:13-4, it says,
"He doeth great wonders, so that he
maketh fire come down from heaven on the
earth in the sight of men, and deceives
them that dwell on the earth by means of
those miracles which he had power to do
in the sight of the beast."
How is he deceiving those who are still
on earth? Because everybody's still
going to be on earth. The wheat and the
tears are growing together. How is he
deceiving them? by the miracles,
people are going to fall for their
senses. They're going to say, "I see it.
I believe it." They're not standing on
thus sayeth the Lord, the word of God.
They're falling for their senses and
emotions and and what their senses tell
them.
Many people are going to fall for those
miracles. You think they're going to be
believers?
Are there going to be righteous people
that fall for these miracles? Look what
it says right here. For there shall
arise false Christ and false prophets,
and shall show great signs and wonders
in so much that if it were possible,
they shall deceive the very elect.
Notice the very elect are still here.
That remnant that Revelation talks about
is still on the earth, but they're
sealed and they're not falling for this
because they have been studying the the
prophecies. No, look. It says, "If it
were possible," meaning they're they're
not here. I've heard people say that. It
says, "If they were possible," meaning
they're not on earth, and that's why
it's not possible. Well, explain this
verse. 1 Timothy 4:1 and2 says, "Now the
spirit expressly says that in the latter
times, some will depart from the faith."
This is not the lost. We're not talking
about the lost. The lost can't depart
from the faith because they never had
it. giving heed to deceiving spirits and
doctrines of demons, speaking lies and
hypocrisy, having their own conscience
seared with a hot iron. So,
is this talking about a time where only
the wicked are on earth? No. There are
people who are departing from the faith.
And why are they departing from the
faith? Giving heed to seducing spirits
and doctrines of demons. Those are the
false Christs that are showing signs and
wonders. Those are the the deceiving
spirits and doctrines of demons. They're
the prophets, the doctrines. They're the
false Christs, the miracles.
The elect are here, and some, it doesn't
say all, some will depart from the
faith.
Ephesians 6:12 says, "For we do not
wrestle against flesh and blood, but
against principalities, against powers,
against the rulers of the darkness of
this age, against spiritual hosts of
wickedness in the heavenly places.
What is this talking about? This is
literally talking about Satan, the
prince of the power of the air, flying
around over the cities of the earth on
on the news. The military is telling us,
the news is telling us that these things
are real. That there are aliens from
another world. But what does it say?
This is wickedness in heavenly places.
That Satan is the god of this world.
that he that he is the ruler of this
world.
That's who's coming.
Not aliens, not visitants from another
world. I got a whole video on that that
proves beyond a shadow of a doubt that
these beings are not physical beings
that just
appear when somebody's meditating. Okay?
You can't channel. If there's little
green men on another planet light years
away, why do they magically appear when
somebody goes out to a field and
meditates and prays to summon them? How
can they channel these beings?
How can they defy physics? They appear
and disappear. They make 90° turns at
3,000 m an hour. All of this defies
physics. These beings are not physical
beings. They're spiritual beings and
they're about to manifest into our
world. This is what Alice Bailey
predicted about the externalization of
the hierarchy happening in the year
2025. It's here, guys. Satan's plan is
unrolling right before our very eyes.
In Revelation 16:13, 14, it says, "I saw
three unclean spirits like frogs."
These unclean spirits are like frogs.
And it says that they are the spirits of
devils. What are they doing? Working
miracles.
This is a huge lie that Satan said that
Satan has set up to make you believe
that he's this monster with goat legs
and horns and all he can do is bring
fear and death. But no, he does
miracles. And what's he doing? He's
going forth unto the kings of the earth
and the whole world to gather them to
the battle of that great day of God
Almighty. So what is happening? Satan is
about to appear
as an angel of light as the cosmic
saviors of the world at a time when we
have lost hope in everything.
We're talking the Nickelodeon
documentary,
the Diddy Files, the Epstein Files. All
of this stuff is happening right now.
Why? Because Satan is collapsing our
hope in everything so that he can be our
savior. This is order out of chaos.
He's setting the stage for a hopeless
world, seeking a savior. And we're going
to think, "Wow, this world is literally
satanic. Look at these people doing
satanic rituals on stage. Look at these
presidents eating babies. These people
are are demons. And then Satan's going
to appear as an angel of light doing
miracles.
And the whole world's going to wonder
after him and say, "This is our savior.
This is going to be the most deceiving
thing that's ever happened to humanity."
More deceiving than what happened in the
garden. Or maybe comparable. If Satan
can deceive Eve, a perfect being in a
perfect world where there's no such
thing as deception, how much more are we
going to fall prey to deception?
Deception like seeing a supernatural
being that we've never seen before, an
angel of light doing lion, signs, and
wonders. I believe that the UFO thing is
not to distract us from the Epstein
files, but rather it's the other way
around.
All of these things are bringing us to
hopelessness so that we will embrace
these cosmic saviors that are coming.
And they're going to talk like Jesus.
They're going to talk about love and
peace and safety and coexist. And what
does it say when they say peace and
safety? Sudden destruction will come
upon them. Do not fall for these beings.
I don't care how loving they seem, how
much emotion they can make you feel. I
made a video. Check out on our video
section of a military guy that picked up
an egg-shaped craft and carried it with
a helicopter. And he said he was
overcome by emotions and he was weeping
and crying and he said, "I know that all
I could feel was love."
This is what these beings make you feel.
Chris Bledsoe, a self-professed
Christian, says that these demonic
beings are angels because they healed
him. He did not test the spirits. He
simply believed the false miracles, the
the lying signs and wonders. And this is
what's soon to come upon the whole
world. If you are not standing on the
word of God alone and the pro the
prophetic events, you will fall for the
strong delusion. I hope this made sense
to you guys. I hope this was powerful.
If it was, please click a thumbs up or
click a thumbs down. Either way helps
the algorithm. Put a comment in the
comment section if you think you can
prove the pre-tribulation rapture. Help
this video get out into the algorithm by
simply saying amen. Or tell us what you
thought about it. You can support this
channel by going to cantruth.org. We got
Cash App, Vinmo, Zel, PayPal. We even
have Patreon, and we have a lot of cool
merchandise. If you want to go to our
website, we get about $5 per sale,
whether it's mug, hoodie, t-shirt, all
of that goes to help this ministry stay
possible because we are 100%
donationbased. If you would like to
invite us to your event, school, uh,
youth group, church, house, you can book
us. Go check out our booking tab on our
website and we will come give these
presentations for you. If you guys have
been given to this ministry, we see you.
We love you. We thank you. We cannot do
this without you.